yeah yeah he was that open the door yeah
so basically and then he open the door
and then he came in and then someone an
idiot let me show you every darkness so
for example this is yogurt that we have
here
[Music]
by any limo feed the power
Salam alaikum warahmatullah verkehr tube
of the sisters indifference so as I
promised you guys inshallah gonna have a
little discussion with my mom she's in
the kitchen she's made it I'm hungry
just got back from the park so I'm gonna
eat opening insha'Allah and this is the
door my dad came in from yes it's how he
caught me yeah I'm gonna talk a bit
about which I was gonna be a bit
beneficial okay I think we're very bit
which I think a lot of people will start
praying someone shot after this our
kitchen you can say so my mom's cooking
food I'm not gonna show you her she's
made this is called
Salma so basically it's like vine leaves
and you can have like cabbage and you
feel it with minced meat and some herbs
stuffer that's all I'm gonna be eating
and talking okay yeah so basically I've
got another I've got my ipod recording
as well so I would be changing camera
angles so this is exactly yeah so
basically I was I was here yes I was
basically or just standing right right
there so when I heard the doc would
usually what it is is for the past five
or six years but that
well obviously the last about two years
he kind of people have you got some
customers and they tell and they tell
him about me so it's kind of recently
about year and a half two years ago they
find out about my each other stuff which
they're not really happy about but
praying was the first time ever like I
think he actually caught me praying
cause usually when I hear him this was
before that time ago it would be really
bad like I would have to stop praying
cuz if he saw me it just would have been
for me too bad not that he's a bad
person it's just the things that has
been through a few extra few other stuff
is worth so it's not that he's a bad
person I only got to stop thinking on
others but it's not that because it's a
really very nice person but it's just
you know it's just at the stuff that is
gone free yes I don't mean a bit bitter
and you know just things you know I'm
brain wars of cetera it's a different
story Bob asked Allah to guide and
inshallah and there's a lot of people
out there with the same issue as well so
yeah I was just I was standing there
when I heard the door
a concealer from the corridor from here
right for example you guys so basically
from there you can see that's the
corridor yet so I'm I'm praying here so
imagine I'm praying here so I know from
there he's gonna see me yeah so what I
do is I thought I went a bit forward
here so he wouldn't see my went really
close and my mom standing or something
and my mom's mom I'm standing basically
here yeah more standing right here yeah
no no she starts pretty clear no this is
so basically okay she's going to in
Turkish I can do translation back trying
on the screen if that's too long I'm
just going to for years she's been
saying that she used to be careful she
would look at the door you know see you
know for me basically um ah mmm
so basically um she's saying that when
my dad came and caught me because he see
this two things up in the air one month
ago I was upstairs yeah and that's when
he the first ever time he caught me
praying yeah the second time is this
instance I'm telling you that instance
when it first happened that was a con
explained to you I don't go into detail
if some certain things happened and I
was praying and he came so I was
upstairs yeah he came I thought my mum
Kim so he's coming he came into the room
I'm praying and he's like what are you
doing yeah and imagine I'm in prayer
usually I break my Solaria I was some
things that happened I can't explain to
you but I just froze I was I I could not
explain the feeling the most awkward
feeling
ever like it's like do i stock what do I
do and he's like why like what are you
doing yeah literally imagine you don't
even look at Mike and it was the most
awkward thing ever
obviously uh I just carried on I don't
know why I just carried on here and then
afterwards I'm thinking in my head like
the system was awkward thing ever
because I'm eventually gonna finish
praying and I can I heard that he just
sat there watching me so imagine how
awkward is yeah those who are reverts or
those who are Muslim families who you
know Muslim families their families
maybe don't like them praying we're here
but sometimes reverse I think mean in
Reverse before this they would know so
when you finish prayer imagine given you
didn't just leave me okay and then you
turn it and you're gonna turn this side
yeah and then easy and he's dead as soon
as I finished prayer and who's the most
awkward thing ever
what I did is I just I just wanted to
walk out here and I was just I didn't
wanna put my head down I was just trying
to go here and then I was he was angry
in his life don't ever pray here again
accessory such a few other things but
like I say to you before you he's coming
from the angle where you know he just
look you need to understand things at
this year like it's like a look at the
Companions all of them they accepted
Islam later on in life etc at the begin
their Worcester Umar bin khattab Rodino
and you know he was even though some
days regeneration he was on the way to
kill the Prophet peace be upon him so
they were hostile while cuz they didn't
know no better so we should not look at
these people as evil you know we should
make pray for them whoever yeah so yeah
that was the first ever time yeah
so the second time my mom doesn't know
mom doesn't know that first time he saw
me so I always am in a little bit more
comfortable so so basically he's walking
through that door I go right well this
is yeah I come very close to it yeah so
it doesn't see me so he's open the door
yo yo orthodontist again with each other
yeah he was like open the door yet so
basically and then you know it's just
like cold and then he open the door and
then he came in and then tomorrow
medieval Michelle is on so she seemed
she seemed to be cut up cut up cuz I
haven't told her my mum's my - Swami
crane once yet so I'm in a little bit
more contra is still very walking like I
tried to avoid it cause I don't wanna
rub in his face here um though I'm just
carrying on cuz I'm just inviting again
but I'm just kinda so mom's thinking
it's the first ever she's thinking
what's going on why is he not getting up
what are you doing like usually sprained
been busting do mean what
[Music]
yeah cuz I'm saying that usually penico
then you get up but he was this like
this time he goes you did it so I see my
my dad comes in here it was like what
are you doing the idiot
stop stop kissing the floor yeah
let's pray there but he was it was so
casual a hablas he was shocked your
mom's prom surprise just came he just
sat down and he just it just went
upstairs so yeah that's about it that's
that's what happened yet yeah so
basically the reason I told you this is
obviously not not with the intentions of
boasting about it not with the
intentions of making this seem like I
did something extraordinary something
special but in a nutshell the reason I'm
doing this for my sister is well I've
something for to come here yeah so
basically the reason why I was I'm
sharing this with you guys as well yeah
and just given you know the tape as well
[Music]
she's made the vine leaves and the dogma
but she's saying that she wants to put
some sauce on it wasn't taste better
with that when it comes to this I'm sure
this forces me even when I mean I can't
yeah that's mother sweet love listen
that's what I'll always tell him said
you know when they ask who has my more
rights I said your mother didn't who
your mother then who your mother then
your father obviously should be great
we're grateful and appreciative and
respectful to our parents and their your
daughter Germany you know lost from the
final thoughts is Miranda after he
orders us to worship Him to obey the
parents be their Muslim or non-muslim so
yeah you know the reason why I'm sharing
this with you Bob and sisters is that
it's it's I heard of heard of a lot of
stories mine is nothing the offered of
masters where the core praying the
parent comes spits in their face
physically attack yeah I'm them haven't
haven't gone through that madness here I
know a lot of people now there is times
those times I'll never mention here for
you guys that there is times I can
remember when I would have to do would
do and I'm sure a lot of reverb bombers
or those who are struggling certain
families face that getting up for budget
is a struggle on its own yeah but for
Reavers it's not the struggle off okay
you know some really the struggle is
what I'm gonna make it seem like reverts
do something special but the struggle of
waking up for fighters that's another
problem with itself but another thing is
the fact that you have to get up knowing
your parents if you're both your parents
are not okay with it your sister brother
with me which is my father yeah yeah my
guidance I mean so basically is that you
have to get inside of it
yeah so the issue is not just oh I'm
gonna wait for fudge in our car and wake
up in the morning no the issue is you
have to get up in silence so imagine you
get up in silence yeah
so you're walking down you're tiptoeing
man like what line is literally I can
remember time wait you I would have to
tiptoe yeah and I know a lot of people
go up freezes well you're ticked over
it's time to pray then when you go and
do what all you have to open the taps oh
honey you need to do what's the fun the
fun if you do it one time here the
Hansen yeah okay then you know you have
to do three times yeah that's you know
the father is but you do it once yeah
that you won't have to do once it's over
yeah
and then will you do you know so they
don't hear it when you're praying when
you go into the center when you're
reciting you're doing it all slowly all
of it yeah now why am i mention this to
you got fallen sister the reason I'm
mentions reason is because so you guys
can understand one like there's so many
of you guys that your families are
encouraging you to play pray yeah they
are encouraging you to pray and you know
what I'm amazed is not about less people
who watch lock them in Yanni strive in
blood sweat and tears to pray miss
driving to pray and they are under like
you know that CCTV surveillance cameras
everything kind of off yet and they
don't manage in the pre so I don't look
at some of you guys who are Muslim
families your mom and your dad they want
you to play in your not plane
look at our situation look at what we
have to go through I'm not trying to be
a victim your black people feel safe
from what my don't stray from I don't
want no one to feel sorry for me what
I'm seeing is think about it think about
it people are getting beaten up cuz
they're clean by the family members
getting kicked out of their house yeah
it's tough to miss a spot in their face
yeah so why aren't you trying to seek
you guys I want you guys to benefit from
this your soul oh yeah no salaam
worshipping almost plan without some
people are dying they begin to worship
allah spy what's up and sit over at
dying not the worship allah subhanho wa
taala
just install and you guys benefit from
this that you learn in sha allah and you
take your religion seriously in shallow
bowl and sisters what why these people
like the other side or the planet around
the world even in London you know that
are struggling to pray they're looking
for a way out to pray Allah so yeah it
was just no reminder for me so you guys
were mom of what happened let me show
you guys benefited my mom was featured
in my marriage documentary where we have
a discussion with her them onion very
media so basically we talked with my mom
about what my dad was obviously allowed
me to get married to a listen sister the
struggles that I went through you know
she says you know I I have a you know
hot hormone which she talks about in
general what happened the struggles I
went through the reason why my dad was
like that except that's only on my
documentary show a lot especially my mom
likes all my friends Angela but
specifically watch this reaction here
she I have to learn it
Shakeel do it by mistake
my mom has a special kind of love potion
- so if you're watching this yeah my mom
always talks about me I love listen
Charlotte you should and you should come
visit
look she's even asking about she's like
where is he you know rubbish cool Romero
may Allah bless inshallah you know his
mom passed away I mean under grant
Jenner she accepted Islam and yeah
so make dua for his mom as well
inshallah and doing these videos what
lies it is hard for me because the thing
is I tried to really foster of you know
you know there's a statement a common
who said they actually to other doctor
and that you know don't talk about your
children except keep people that don't
have kids don't talk about it well next
to the poor and you know obviously I
think should I do this video cuz
obviously I know she kills when I watch
it and his mother's possible and there's
a lot of people's parents pasta as well
it was a very hard decision for me but
for them the benefit outweighs the good
hamdulillah I should feel hungry is a
very strong person strong Baba may Allah
bless him is one shot life is watching
this I love him for the sake of allah
subhanaw taala hope you guys are
benefited in shoulder shake your mom on
saying you know come visit inshallah and
thing goes with musa and the wood and
the wood
mashallah may Allah bless you guys yeah
that's it guys hope you guys been
affected I'm gonna have my vine leaves
and ya know
Oh rusty soon I might be doing a little
problem with my mom
I'm gonna I'm gonna be doing a little
problem with my mom
oh she's gonna tell us how to make
Turkish dishes so what I mean now I'm
gonna do a footage we're sisters your
wives your sisters whoever they can
watch and learn how to make this kind of
food so for example this yoga that we
have here yeah okay okay so basically
this your butt here my mom made this
homemade yogurt so I'm going to be doing
a little show with her for the Salaam
Bannon show showing you guys how to make
this at home these kind of things that's
why I promised Ismail
that's watching don't forget to
subscribe share and like I want from
every single one of you guys for
supporting our works and make the offer
us me to other was Panasonic guys my
father Islam and the rest till next time
for me and my mom
Sarang wali Salam Salam alaikum I've
ever get to see you at the mouth of a
tree